[Music]
forget a doomsday asteroid or melting
permafrost
it's the freezing of the earth's core
that will end the world in today's
episode
or would it
because maybe
just maybe
we could save the world by heating earth
from the inside
what is happening down in the earth's
core
what would happen if the core froze
completely
and would we have a chance of fixing the
earth before it's too late
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could reheat the earth's
core
you've probably never noticed that the
earth's core is freezing but it is
it's just happening very slowly
about four and a half billion years ago
the entire core was molten
but over billions of years the earth has
slowly cooled from the inside out
causing parts of its molten iron outer
core to freeze
and if this process significantly sped
up in a flash freeze event
we'd need to do something about it
the earth's core does more for our
planet than you might imagine
without it what would happen to you
earth has a magnetic field that
surrounds it and protects you from
radiation
this field is created by
you guessed it our planet's core
heat transfers from the super hot inner
core
through the outer core and into the
mantle
this heat exchanging process called
convection
creates a current of liquid metal in the
outer core
and the flow of liquid metal generates
electrical currents
which extend into space
to form that essential magnetic field
but if earth's core were frozen solid
there would be no current in the outer
core and there would be no magnetic
field
all of a sudden we would have no
protection from the ultraviolet
radiation bombarding earth
you'd have no more fun in the sun
because
now the sun would be deadly even plants
wouldn't be able to survive the intense
uv rays
you'd have to grow all your food inside
as if you lived on an alien planet
and you basically would be because the
earth's magnetic field also keeps our
atmosphere in place
without it solar winds would strip earth
of its breathable and safe atmosphere
our planet would start looking more like
mars than the earth we know and love
but would there be any way for you to
escape this fate
you could jump on a spaceship assuming
those still exist
and leave earth but
where would you go
any other planet would be just as
hostile as the dying earth if not more
your best bet would be to dedicate every
brain cell you have to help the world
reheat the earth's core
what could we do it before it's too late
well we just might be able to but we
need to know what made the core so hot
before it froze
well there are three reasons
the first is leftover heat from the
process of accretion which is how earth
formed basically earth was once just a
tiny core seed but it was able to gather
more and more material into itself
growing larger and larger
every time a new material crashed into
the growing earth it generated
incredible amounts of heat which got
trapped inside the core
the second reason earth keeps its toasty
inner temperature is called frictional
heat when earth was young it underwent
gravitational sorting
the denser and heavier parts including
iron and nickel sank into the center
the less dense substances like oxygen
and water
floated outward
this created friction and generated heat
the main reason our planet is so hot is
because of radioactive decay
as radioactive isotopes decay in earth's
mantle they produce heat
but
could we successfully reproduce any of
these phenomena
well uh we can't go back in time to when
earth formed and
we can't create more friction in the
core so
we'd only have one method left to try
and that would be adding more radiation
to it
which means
we'd need to drill a giant hole
but not just any hole we'd have to drill
all the way down to the mantle where
radioactive decay happens
so we drill through the ocean floor
where the crust is usually thinner
no one has ever drilled into the mantle
before the closest anyone got was back
in 2005 when the integrated ocean
drilling program board a whole 1416
meters deep in the north atlantic ocean
but let's say that the world would come
together under the threat of impending
doom and create the most sophisticated
drill ever
[Music]
once we drilled beneath the sea floor
all we'd have to do is pump the mantle
full of potassium uranium and thorium
these elements would decay and generate
heat but would that be enough to reheat
earth's core
it could eventually but there would be a
drawback
all the heat from radioactive decay
would be in the mantle not the inner or
outer core
it wouldn't recreate the life-saving
magnetic field
for that we'd need the outer core to
melt
oh okay so back to the drawing board it
looks like we'd need to do something
we've never done before if we want to
save humanity
and
this time
we'd have to drill all the way to the
outer core
2 900 kilometers deep
because we'd be building an ultra high
energy particle accelerator thousands of
miles long
deep into the earth
this particle accelerator would harness
the sun's power and pump energy into the
earth's outer core
once the outer core reheats
it would generate the electrical current
and create the magnetic field
but here's the thing
the pressure inside the inner core is so
extreme that iron atoms are not able to
become liquid
this is why the inner core is so
incredibly hot and solid
the intense pressure would make any
tunnel we tried to drill immediately
collapse
so
even if we could build that advanced
particle accelerator
we wouldn't be able to use it
but at least we would give it our best
shot
and maybe you should have hopped on that
spaceship
there we are yet again the freezing of
the earth's core would be death to us
all
luckily scientists estimate that it
would take
91 billion years for the core to
solidify completely
and
seeing how the sun will become a red
giant star in about five billion years
the earth cooling is the last thing
you'd need to worry about
now an exploding sun wouldn't be all
that fun to see but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]